the students of Hogwarts definitely had
their fair share of mishaps behind the
scenes the blooper reel is full of
pranks wardrobe malfunctions forgotten
lines and awkward kisses that
undoubtedly make the films even more fun
number one who knew newspaper could be
so dangerous
I'm sorry Emma Watson might have hit
Daniel Radcliffe a little too hard
I'm kidding okay sorry um quite a lot
even she knew it she could not keep a
straight face after ask someone I like
if you're laughing because you hit me so
hard don't you okay just your
run-of-the-mill Chosen One casualties
you really can't hear the crunch yeah
paper on bone number two Tom Felton
serves an iconic Draco Malfoy line one
that wasn't originally in the script do
you remember this Chamber of Secrets
moment reading
I don't know you could read Tom actually
forgot his line here and while trying to
pull it out of his head he threw out
this random one that inevitably became a
fan favorite Bravo Tom Bravo
you're absolutely right Saint
otter number three even the adults have
fun on this set Michael gambin and Alan
Rickman played a notorious prank on
Daniel Radcliffe and the other students
who were shooting a scene in the Great
Hall all of the students were supposed
to be asleep on the floor with Daniel
placed next to a girl he liked in real
life in our dreams we enter completely
our own world
Alan and Michael hit a fart machine in
Daniel's sleeping bag Michael stayed in
character throughout his entire
monologue next to Alan who was really
trying hard to keep it together it's
completely our own world and we'd like
to swim in the deepest Waters it wasn't
until all the students finally broke out
into laughter that Alan and Michael
finally broke character themselves
number four there's bound to be a ton of
bloopers for this one I think we kind of
built it up into this kind of really
awkward horrible kind of thing Emma
Watson and Rupert Grint have known each
other for so long they literally grew up
together on the sets of these movies to
them the kiss was less of a romantic
moment and more like kissing a sibling
we were both more worried about the fact
that we just wouldn't be able to do it
luckily they did manage to get the shot
after only a few tries Emma decided she
needed to commit really early so they
didn't have to do a ton of takes I just
kind of had to put the incredible amount
of history that I have with Rupert a
size and the Hermione number five this
time it's Daniel Radcliffe and Bonnie
Wright like Emma Watson and Rupert Grint
Daniel felt pretty weird about doing the
scene with her it was kind of odd
because I've known Bonnie since she's
about 10. guess how many takes it took
them to get right quite a weird thing to
have to do so I think it was kind of
tried to cut cut each other some
if you guessed 30 takes you'd be right
their nurse kept getting the better of
them and they found it difficult to get
the kiss done naturally or rather
without laughing during each take so
we're doing all that but it's it's fine
number six okay this is the last kiss
we're gonna mention here poor Emma
Watson I was half naked and covered in
silver paint so that was pretty awkward
we were talking of course about Harry
and Hermione's kiss for Daniel Radcliffe
the kiss was significantly less awkward
to be honest it wasn't too awkward it's
quite enjoyable
um I I quite liked it that smooch took
five takes with each actor clearly
having two very different experiences
number seven Daniel Radcliffe had
childhood nerves of Steel at Mr Harry
Potter has his key
the director really wanted to scare
Daniel so he instructed Warwick Davis
who was playing the goblin to go really
over the top and yell at him but Harry
Potter have his key
it made Daniel start cracking up
laughing instead number eight bras can
be a tricky thing sometimes well look
away I'm hideous in Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows part one Daniel got to
try on an outfit he wouldn't usually
find in his section of the Wardrobe
closet that was one of the things I was
delighted about was how good I looked at
the First costume on a fantastic in
women's clothing that scene and a slight
wardrobe malfunction was the reason for
this hilarious blooper bill
number nine Emma Watson just couldn't
keep it together where is Luna Luna
for this scene in the Deathly Hallows
Harry Ron and Hermione are having tea at
beloved goods and Emma just couldn't
handle all the slurping sounds
she was threatened with the harrowing
red card and after his penalization for
ruining takes not always such the
straight A student red card and Watson
number 10. Matthew Lewis has all the
comedic timing and the world for this
take my grant said it's a daily profit
that's rubbish
your cast and crew laughing they had to
go in for a few more takes afterwards
that comedic timing we were
my grand says it's the daily Prophet
that's rubbish
just cancel that subscription number
eleven apparently Rupert finds
everything funny you just shut your
mouth I do you just shut your mouth he
was known on set as the one who was
constantly ruining takes with his
laughter once he gotten one of his
giggle fits it was impossible to get him
to stop as soon as he goes I'm I'm I
Fall to Pieces I'm gone when he starts
laughing he can't stop and apparently it
was like that from the very beginning
number 12. Emma Watson needed a second
to gather her thoughts here uh just
because I laughed as we have to stop it
seems as if she lost her train of
thought in this Goblet of Fire scene
luckily though we didn't hear anything
about another red card this time number
13 not everyone has a natural rhythm in
my mind I could see myself everyone
going oh he's such a good dancer wow and
it didn't happen to be fair though when
preparing for the Yule Ball Daniel
Radcliffe didn't have as much time to
learn the steps as everyone else did
everyone else about three weeks
I only had about four days to learn he
said he had it until about halfway
through the dance and then it would kind
of all fall apart for him at the minute
God did not necessarily mean him to be a
ballroom dancer as far as his character
acting goes he says Harry wouldn't be a
great dancer either so he was actually
delivering his performance perfectly
number 14 or was it actually wuss these
quidditch matches can really get heated
whoops
it's clear that regardless of their
character's rivalry these actors have
great Rapport
we love each other really yeah I have
Polaroids that I can show you of Tom
shut up now shut up who says gryffindors
and slytherins can't be friends number
15 kids can be pretty forgetful kids one
thing everybody's forgetting after his
spell everybody goes instead of reacting
in shock or worry to this chamber of
secret scene everyone was just kind of
well there Emma really big reaction from
you you're staring in horror this is
your friend okay after a friendly
reminder from the director everyone was
able to get the proper reaction to
Professor Lockhart's spell
we've got pranks wardrobe malfunctions
giggle fits awkward kisses and short
detention spans peppered through every
film in the Harry Potter franchise which
of these moments over the years was your
favorite